making McCain just through some major
shade at Kourtney Kardashian I don't
care what anyone says it all went down
on the view when Whoopi Goldberg intro'd
a new trailer for the upcoming season of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians in the
cliff Courtney is seen getting pretty
emotional over turning 40 I do think
that turning 40 like it almost makes you
analyze like where you're at in your
life
I just always wish I had more time but I
feel like I want to cry just cause like
gives me anxiety
really I don't know why would be kinda
mock the reality star before showing the
clip Courtney it's about to turn 40
years old and she's not dealing with it
too well Chuck a look I have so much and
I should just be so happy but you're
unhappy I mean I am but then sometimes
I'm just like it makes you really like
family it's just like where you're at
and I'm like sometimes like what am i
doing after showing the clip Whoopi even
dramatically lays out on the floor in
response
backlashes my life and mccain wasted no
time jumping in to blast the reality
star for her attitude not to be like
debbie downer on this you have all the
money opportunities life advantages in
the entire world there people can't feed
their children I did not feel bad but
sunny Austin and Joy Behar shared some
encouraging words for the oldest
Kardashian sister she's upset because
she's turning 40 she's reading
how was she her mommy they say life
begins at 40 so she's dealt with the
program it starts at 40 they get hiccup
forties a good feel lucky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]